how's going bros my name is peter pan so
there's been an increase of the the good
old hate now and especially with youtube
revved and scare PewDiePie coming out
along with it a lot of people are upset
and that is mean an increase in hater
videos there's one challeng particular
called PewDiePie's sucks i like their
banner they have some great videos let's
have a look first off we have this video
called pewdiepie sucks he looks like a
horse
that's me flying away as a rocketship
through space I like the graphic you can
see here clearly that the fire is not
synced to me so I would say that this is
fake but let's keep watching flying into
the Sun
I explode in the Sun
this is the soundtrack of Space Odyssey
Oh Peter pie sucks and it's the worst
youtuber no joke they're not even gonna
make a horse resemblance okay here's a
here's another good one we do pie sucks
bro army sucks I hate pity pie comment
your opinion kids I have a plan this is
all it really motivational is making me
have a guy who's a plan we need to kill
him and then
rope him then we will all going to rope
marzia too and she will give us a blow
there since they censored it I don't
know what they're trying to tell you
know people criticize my fans for being
a bit crazy but you know this is just
batshit [ __ ] insane
there's also some videos and let's see
Mike [ __ ] baby by baby but as I hate
PewDiePie makeup pdaboy sucks and heat
and sucks fanboys sucks
PewDiePie sucks I hate [ __ ] 50 pi
don't call me fat because you fat too
[ __ ]
you are the chosen one
my brother Anakin
a lot of hate in his heart I can
appreciate that I can respect that
PewDiePie sucks I like what they did
here with the the text he is a [ __ ]
and money [ __ ] get over it you stupid
kids I'll bet you my youtube channel
this guy's not above 10 and if he is I'm
actually concerned your PewDiePie sucks
his laugh is so annoying na+
how does he how was he in like a good
relationship like he's so weird and
everything dude you're 12 what are you
talking about what do you think you
understand it's just he's so childish to
so if anyone watches him or subscribe to
him you suck that's a good point
so Peter price sucks he's so childish
and he probably just makes videos for
money and I don't know he's just so
stupid and you know when people make a
good case I'll
I just have to be humble and accept so I
think this guy is clearly right oh [ __ ]
this guy's back bye sucks oh god I hate
baby bye why does he hate me so much
what did I do
looking for money I am working for the
money I must be the only one in the
world who does that
so this video goes out to PewDiePie why
he shot that went that went south so
fast dude I thought it was gonna be nice
first of all you teppanyaki in front of
a computer playing video games and you
makes you money for that somehow all
these fans are dying your kids how old
are you so why should they just be
watching this guy play video games AC
molding their prey
I'll show you you buy the screams and
doing camera what are you doing right
now you're caught you're this close to
the [ __ ] camera I will attack you oh
I'll go to Sweden myself and attack you
I'm gonna go get a jet pack right now
and find you and attack you okay
are the only one that I will not spare
be afraid that's it
I'm quitting YouTube he's chasing me is
angry by sucks like a song
slow deep I suck sucks it's not a bad
song my dancing sucks
okay well that was me and reacting to
some hater videos I think most of them
are trolling I am Not sure like what the
context is behind it but I I find it
hard to believe that they're all real uh
maybe some are I don't know but it's
funny and I don't know I don't and it's
like what I said before people always
like say that my friends are childish
and then you see like how the other end
of it is and it's just ten times worse
than people described so anyway thank
you for watching this video I really
appreciate it thanks for leaving it like
and I will see you bros in the next
video and as always stay awesome you
want a dish you look like an Australian
food if I saw like racism